Remember the problem solving framework?
We ran the model with two
different variables and
obtained pretty good results.
Next, we combined the variables and
achieved better results.
Repeating the analysis, modeling, and
validation steps helped
us create a better model.
The key takeaway is that you
should question your data and
explore options to determine the best
model for your data and use case.
We just worked through an example of
iterating through the analytical problem
solving process to
obtain the best result.
Using both predictor variables,
in this example,
results in a better model with
a higher level of correlation.